[Musik]
bali ist die insel der götter und die
meinten es gut mit einem kleinen mädchen
das und touristen tag für tag die
schwere tauchausrüstung an den strand
druck die götter schickten ihm einen
mann und eine frau aus der schweiz
so fing es an dieses moderne
balinesische schweiz frische milch
[Musik]
die lampen im norden von bari chris und
troy clarke aus einsiedeln sind
angefressene taucher jedes jahr
verbringen die beiden zwei bis drei
wochen im un unter wasser
so auch im jahr 2000 hier auf der
indonesischen ferieninsel bali und dem
morgen wenn die ganz frühe haus sind ist
nur dass dieses mal am strand sie und
sie hat offeriert dass sie es tauchte
betreibt aber sie sind nicht so viel
gewicht tragen richtung und alles sind
was schwierig ist genommen hat bundes
dass das maximal vertrages reden und sie
hat diese irgendwie einfach gedruckten
macht mit ihrer ort so fröhlich sie und
dann haben wir geben dieses tasche
master class tasche maserati und eines
ganzen durchgegangen zum parkplatz
zurück stunden
herr cdu luft geht zum allen zeigen sagt
meister überholt und als prognose in dem
hemmschwelle ihre weise wegner hat sie
sich das ist - das sage ich jetzt hier
und das hat sich irgendwie erinnert das
fröhliche mal die täter
zwei jahre später im sommer 2002 komme
ich ins spiel
respektive die allererste ausgabe der
reise sendung einfach luxuriös daniela
lager und ich besuchten die götter insel
bali und erfüllten in jeder sendung
einen zuschauer wunsch so kam es dass
ich für chris und troy clarke auf die
suche ging nach dem mädchen dass ihnen
zwei jahre vorher das tauch equipment an
den strand trug und von dem es lediglich
an voll zucker
kennen sie dieses mädchen
sie waren sie treffen
und wie heißt sie
[Musik]
das ist
märz bis 1
jetzt
[Musik]
ja
ob ich das
so beschwert
es ist
und wenn man gleitet und betrüger selbst
auswählen der dreharbeiten es vermutlich
gestorben ich mein tv und jetzt ist die
ganze familie einen ziemlichen zustand
kindern im schul und kein geld und
möchtegerns patenschaft übernehmen
sie erinnere ich nochmal das kind und
vater pauli
das hat es dazu auch das mitmachen
[Musik]
elf jahre sind seither vergangen das
balinesische patenkind mit namen kid
besuchte die grundschule dann die
mittelschule studierte schließlich an
der universität in china und ist heute
22-jährige englischlehrerin der
mittelschule in denkbar sind chris & roy
midget verabredet vor drei jahren haben
sie ihre patentochter das letzte mal
gesehen damals linke tut selber noch zur
schule trug eine uniform und farbige
schleifchen in den haaren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die gelandet das sind meine eltern aus
der schweiz
tarragona du dann so ok labs week zu wie
du
[Musik]
die bomben zerrissen
diese rose anfang hat angeschlagen und
die erste wörter und letzte band jetzt
konnten wir sind total stolz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
daher ist der minimal
zehn stunden unterrichtet cut pro woche
daneben gibt sie noch ein paar privat
lektionen alles in allem verdient sie
pro monat rund anderthalb millionen
indonesische rupien umgerechnet 130
franken 40 franken kostet die monatliche
miete für das kleine zimmer mit bad und
kochnische das geht unter der woche
bewohnt stolz zeigt sie uns das
abschlusszeugnis und die fotos ihrer
diplomfeier im september 2013
[Gelächter]
du siehst ernst aus auf diesen fotos ja
so geschminkt da kann man sich kaum mit
diesem die blumen kann ich mich für
einen job in der tourismusbranche
bewerben
mit diesem hier als lehrerin im
tourismus würde tut etwas besser
verdienen
trotzdem möchte sie als lehrerin
arbeiten das indonesische highschool
system war denn auch in ihrer
diplomarbeit an der sie vier monate
geschrieben hat wann wusstest du dass du
englischlehrerin werden möchtest
[Musik]
ich hatte eine universität an den
englischlehrer der war sehr hübsch und
gescheit
[Gelächter]
er hat mich inspiriert getippt hat
gleich nach dem studium eine
teilzeitstelle als lehrerin gefunden das
ist nicht selbstverständlich ohne
vitamin b ist es auf bali nämlich fast
unmöglich im staatlichen schulbetrieb
fuß zu fassen
es gibt zu im ersten anlauf einen job
bekommen hat zeugt von ihrer
durchsetzungskraft für dies abschlüsse
habe ich vier jahre lang acht semester
studiert eine ausbildung ist in bali in
indonesien sehr teuer aber jetzt hast du
es geschafft du hast etwas für die
zukunft es hat sich gelohnt
[Musik]
am nächsten tag fahren wir zusammen nach
du lamm ben dem heimatdorf von cat an
der nordküste paris drei stunden dauert
die fahrt quer über die insel durch
zahlreiche darf
[Musik]
dass sie dort
im künstlerdorf mut machen wir einen
kurzen halt in einem kaffeeplantagen
restaurant degustieren typischen bali
kopie
es ist also möglich sehen das so
den ersten treffer wie normale pauli
wenn die besucher aus der ganzen familie
exzesse und zudem kreisen
also wir hatten eigentlich mit ihrer
noch eine indirekte und wie hat sich in
die beziehung eigentlich verändert immer
vorziehen
hast du natürlich dem sinn verändert
dass sie im abstand von zwei bis drei
achsen und sieht darin einen schritt
vorwärts gemacht hat und bezirke besteht
können auf der box war damals erst
morgen mit ihren komplexen kommt doch
das ist nicht außergewöhnlich dass ein
kind auf gewährt wurde
und sie spricht es aus eltern und dass
ich über roma für sie und für jüdische
witze sind und nun unser aber dass sie
es als eltern alle promis wie wir das
erste mal überhaupt dass ist das ist
wirklich wahnsinnig also dadurch dass
sie das so macht die familie
verantwortlich
es ist nicht einfach wenn mehrere
screenshots irgendwo auf der welt und
bekannte das kind gar nicht einig es
geht nur um geld und die ihrer ist es
jetzt wirklich darum gegangen dass sie
eher bezirke und die beziehung ist für
sie immer sehr wichtig sie und böse ist
es einfach mehr verantwortlich sieht
dass sie dass sie
wir betrachten sich als ich definitiv
caro sie hat immer wieder machen wenn
das studium und so und hat das gefühl
wird was mit meinem trainer so
unterstütze gene in den finanziell
sondern auch das nenne ich eine
zweigstelle mission zwar so wählen dass
ihre trotzdem nicht wählen dass sie
jetzt da es spezial rollen berühmt wie
wird sich das entwickelt das manuskript
die hand ist gedanke macht die bedarfs-
und wir haben dankt eigentlich hätte
mich jetzt hier entlang als sie
letztlich geworden und der sich
intermedial los klar und das schweigen
dabei und möchte dass ihre dass er die
chance dass sie nicht abhängig
friedvolles trocken überreden über dich
für deine zukunft
[Musik]
nicht nur die schulausbildung bezahlte
chris und roy vor drei jahren haben sie
gedruckt sein kleines bescheidenes
häuschen finanziert damit sie und ihre
familie nach dem tod des vaters wieder
ein zuhause hat und einen haus tempel
für die ahnen ein wichtiger ort für
wallis vom sozialen aufstieg profitiert
die ganze familie
neben den zwei jüngsten geschwister von
acht kindern insgesamt wohnt auch die
mutter im neuen haus
[Musik]
machen wir einen kleinen rundgang durchs
haus
naja es ist die küche hier in unsere es
war das ist das zimmer meines bruders
er schläft alleine hier er hatte als
junger sein eigenes zimmer und das ist
mein schlafzimmer
ich teile es mit meiner mutter und meine
schwester wir frauen sind rund 8000
franken haben chris und läufe das zwei
zimmer häuschen ausgegeben
irgendwann wird kurz bruder mit seiner
frau hier wohnen und getobt wird nach
der heirat zur familie ihres zukünftigen
mannes ziehen
so will es die tradition auf bali ich
möchte euch meine abrechnung zeigen
meine kürzungen der letzten jahre
ich habe sie alle aufbewahrt was hast du
dir als erstes gekauft mit dem geld von
reue und chris
nancy was denkt ist der echt werden
potenziellen für die schulen stifte
bücher rucksack ich weiß noch dass mich
angerufen es war den spricht weil du
auch für eine schwester eines sack
gekauft hast ja und schuhe und eine
uniform
inzwischen unterstützen chris untreue
auch die ausbildung von tattoos jüngste
schwester marie sie ist 17
ein schuljahr kostet auf bali rund 300
fragen aber das ist nicht nur drei das
ist das ist auch ein anderer meinte dass
wir unterstützen und sich nicht nur
uniform wie auf bali üblich werden wir
zum mittagessen eingeladen
es gibt fisch oder wickelt das wort
ausspricht
[Musik]
während chris hoy und die familie zu
mittag essen
besuche ich den jüngeren bruder von code
im nachbardorf damit seit einem jahr
arbeitet er in einen drive center und
hat sich dort innerhalb eines jahres von
model bei der die tauchflaschen auffüllt
zum tauchlehrer hochgearbeitet von chris
und roy ließ er sich jedoch nie
unterstützen
ich wollte arbeiten kennt verdiene nicht
zur schule gehen
[Musik]
minister dich getan hat alles angefangen
hier haben wir uns getroffen und wir
haben die ein kleine fachmesse geschenkt
ja ich weiß noch ihr habt mir ein klares
messer geschenkt ich hab dir ein neues
blaues messer mitgebracht als erinnerung
an unsere freundschaft als symbol für
ein glückliches leben
es war einmal ein kleines balinesische
mädchen nein ein märchen ist dies nicht
sondern eine erfolgsgeschichte geprägt
von zufällen und wendungen von
entscheidungen und starken wehen eine
geschichte also wie sie nur das leben
schreiben kann und wie geht sie weiter
wie plant ihre zukunft ich möchte eine
erfolgreiche frau sein
ich möchte mich weiterentwickeln ich
möchte dass meine familie es besser hat
als ich es hatte sie soll von anfang an
glücklich sein
meine kleine familie die ich im nächsten
jahr könnten was habt ihr unterstützung
von chinesischer seite zeigen und
braucht jagen
sie hatte ich sehr viel zucker idee
möglich hinter versorger vom
tourismusverband orte dass wir auch
alina familien innenhof das mit kultur
und traditionen können etwas lernen und
nicht nur das schöne ballade götter
insel voll ist und mercedes der armut
gibt das sehr großes problem hat und das
ist besuchen wir dankbar und tagen erst
begegneten haben meiste geld das ich da
erlebt wie sie so freut hat als geschenk
das mir gehört dass sie tanzen durch die
die parkplatz lange nicht mehr hat die
es während der ganzen zeit immer deine
danke vor was mir da für sie richtet und
die haben immer zu schließen
danke du hast es verdient der hesse in
den ersten momenten aus der ganzen durch
die autohersteller das problem
[Musik]